oh my goodness look at this there we go  on to the Buffalo Calf another hyenas  running in all this hyenas coming in  from everywhere there's a big buffalo  bull on his way in but I bet calf is  really sick we just saw it this one two  three four five hyenas charging in this  big buffalo bull charging straight at  the hyenas trying to protect the heart  of the calf now the whole herds coming  the whole herd of buffalo are charging  in there's about 50 Butler's  they're coming in in defense now in all  this is insane all these more hyenas  coming I can just see hyenas coming from  the distance all over the place look  here comes a car she's coming in really  seriously at the hyenas how the coffee  is sickened it really looked sick when  we saw it but look the scales up the  herd of buffalo charging and in defense  so even though the Baffler managed to  chase the hyenas off now I don't think  this cough is going to survive an idea  more hyenas still coming in  [Music]  you